I'm looking right now at our Bloomberg
pan dicks it's available on the terminal
one of the things that you want the
Bloomberg terminal for for sure because
nobody else has this stuff right so this
is what it looks like on a Bloomberg
screen we've got a bunch of names we've
got a bunch of dollars we've got the
companies they work for and the Stars
wanting you to put it under performance
what do those rankings tell us because I
see lots of money and in many cases only
one or two stars next to these peoples
names sure so what are what our pan
decks does it's the first daily ranking
of executive pay we take the current
value of an executives pay package so
based on you know what we gathered on
Nick Woodman he's going to be our
highest paid CEO those stars on the
other hand show pay for performance and
the way we're measuring pay for
performance is with economic profit on a
three-year rolling average rolling basis
and basically that's showing us if
they're creating if that executive is
their decision making is creating
probably delivering exactly above and
beyond their custody lots of people
aren't delivering sure like look at
Sharif Suki currently the highest paid
CEO in America 500 million dollars
that's the current value of his paypal
exactly so he works for a company or he
runs a company called cheniere energy
and we broke the news last year that he
was the highest-paid CEO in the US their
company has never turned a profit they
are sort of banking on this the idea
that they'll be able to export natural
gas it hasn't happened yet so they have
a lot of investments in their
infrastructure and they just haven't you
know been able to peruse the profit yet
so that's why he's he has one star now
let's talk a little bit about Nick
Woodman what's how is he going to top
Sharif Sookie he was granted 4.5 million
restricted shares before the company's
IPO that was back so we found that out
from a prospectus in November those 4.5
million shares were worth about 285
million at the end of the year and
that's how the index is is gauging
awarded pay there were pricing an
executive compensation package as of the
company's fiscal year end so that's how
he's going to end up on seating Sharif
Sookie on our index you have a lot of
time to play with this I'm going to be
playing around with this but it's brand
new what do you find most fascinating
about what we learn looking at these
data you know I think what I'm really
excited about is the ability to see how
a pay package changes in value and you
can see you know on a day-by-day basis
how companies are in executives pay is
tied to their their value their stock
value you know you this is critical
information for boards exactly exactly
and we hope for shareholders to you know
help its shareholders make decisions on
whether or not they approve of a
company's pay package and then of course
it's been quite frankly it's adding
transparency to the process that's all I
hope yeah and and our pay for
performance metric is very unique we
wanted to stay away from total
shareholder return because we know that
a lot of times executives don't have a
whole lot of control over how their
stock price does I mean you could look
at the oil executives for as a perfect
example I mean the price of oil has a
huge impact on their shares but we want
to look at whether they're making
decisions that are covering their cost
of capital and then some which we think
it will provide more value for investors
oh so there is a conspicuous lack of
five star performers in our rankings hey
why is that and be who deserves who
deserves the gold star ok so the gold
star goes to Apple CEO Tim Cook actually
all of apple's management they have
enormous three-year average economic
profit about 28 billion and the way we
measure it it's about Tim Cook gets paid
up to the top three so five of the top
six or Apple executives yes exactly and
and that's because you know they're just
a machine there a gigantic company they
have you know billions of dollars in
revenue they're making decisions that
are that are profitable and so you know
Tim Cook is the best performing CEO and
his whole management team is really
doing a great job according to our index
anything well like I say transparency
boards I hope you're listening if you've
been thinking about getting that
Bloomberg terminal but haven't yet press
the button here's one good reason why